for those who were able to watch it my
appearance on dr phil aired yesterday
afternoon it was my first time appearing
on television outside of fox news and
also my first time meeting with a
psychologist
some would say that i should make more
of a regular habit of it talking to a
psychologist i mean not appearing on tv
but unfortunately
not everybody was able to watch the
discussion i'm told in some market in
some markets it was sidelined by
president biden's press conference i
think we can all agree that of all the
terrible things biden has done during
his disastrous tenure preempting my dr
phil episode is by far the worst
now there's always a certain risk
inherence in walking into an environment
like this
especially with the cameras rolling of
course i knew that i would be
outnumbered on stage in front of a
hostile studio audience
and if i had been invited to speak about
a more complicated or difficult issue
one that requires you to actually be
smart
then um that would have given me pause
but the topic of the episode was gender
and pronouns which means that it's not
complicated or difficult at all
my position the correct position is
extremely simple sensible obvious and
clear
the only mistake that somebody on my
side of the issue can make
and very often people do make this
mistake
in a debate of this kind
is to make the subject seem more
complicated than it is
getting lost in the rhetorical weeds and
losing sight of the main point
that that's where the other side lives
they're out there in the weeds where
things are muddy and muddled
they like it out there they want to
obscure the main point mystifying what
is actually quite simple
as long as you refuse to be baited into
that trap and you stay on message
on the firm ground of truth and science
and common sense you can have this
conversation anywhere with anybody on
any platform in front of any audience
and you will walk away the winner every
time
and if you're a naturally argumentative
bastard like myself you'll even have fun
doing it
that gives you an idea of my basic
strategy so now we'll watch some some
clips of a few of the most important
exchanges during the episode and we'll
see how it played out we'll begin with
the opening salvo which came several
minutes into the episode as the first
segment featured just the two non-binary
diversity consultants
spewing inane garbage unopposed and i
was backstage for that portion just
pacing back and forth listening in
horror
muttering incredulously to myself and
when it was my turn i began by
clarifying that everybody that that you
know everything that was said in the
previous segment was total nonsense and
then we dived into the pronoun question
let's watch
there should be no construct of gender
just sex you're either male or female
right and
someone feeling
in a mental emotional way
that they don't
identify
with the sex that they have
been biologically created as and
assigned at birth based on their
genitalia
if they don't feel that way that there's
no construct that describes that
experiences that well that's got nothing
to do with the realities you can feel
however you want i mean i could sit here
and say that i feel like a tomato plant
but that doesn't mean that i'm actually
in those things so your your
self-perception you can have whatever
self-perception you want but you can't
expect me to take part in that
self-perception or to take part in this
kind of charade this theatrical
production
you don't get your own pronouns just
like you don't get your own prepositions
or your own your own adjectives you know
it's like if i were to tell you
my adjectives are handsome and brilliant
and no matter whenever you're talking
about me you have to describe me as
handsome and brilliant because that's
how i identify it makes no sense you
don't get your own pronouns these are
that's that's grammar that's language so
you think it's a delusion
someone is self-delusional yeah i think
it's it's delusion it could be a mental
illness it could be that's a lot of
different things with children you know
there's also just a basic confusion that
all kids have like that's why when you
hear
when you hear someone a parent say oh my
four-year-old uh son cave came to me and
said that i'm a girl now and so that's
what i'm gonna i'm gonna raise him as a
girl
no you're a four-year-old i have four
kids
when a four-year-old boy comes to you
and says oh i'm a girl here's a good
follow-up question
what is a girl
ask him what he means by that what do
you mean by a girl and when you ask him
that here's what he'll tell you he will
tell you what he really means is that he
he wants to do some of the things that
girls do like play with the dollhouse or
or you know he likes the color pink
that's fine play with a dollhouse
but you're still a boy
i hope you'll respect my preferred
adjectives of course the only problem
with my adjective comparison is that
unlike pronouns adjectives are in fact
subjective
but my point was that the adjectives i
use to describe myself
are products of my self perception i
cannot demand that others perceive me
the way that i perceive myself
my self perception is not a joint
project shared by me and the rest of
human society for adjectives it's up to
each individual to decide which ones
they want to use to describe me and in
my case a great many people use
adjectives to describe me that i find
quite disagreeable i might feel insulted
by some of those adjectives i might lock
myself in the bathroom and weep
uncontrollably for hours because of them
i do that every day
but i cannot say that i'm being erased
or delegitimized because other people
refuse to see me the way that i see
myself
and in fact if their competing
perception
causes some sort of existential crisis
for me
it only proves that i'm not so sure of
my own self-perception and therefore i'm
in no position to criticize anybody
else's perception of me
as for pronouns there is no subjectivity
at all
it's not up to any individual including
myself to decide which ones ought to be
used that question is settled by
biological reality the point of the
pronoun is to describe
that reality
just as the point of a verb like running
unless it's unless it's used
metaphorically is to convey reality if i
say that somebody is running when
they're really sitting
i've conveyed an untruth
whether because i'm confused or a liar
or both and if i call a man a she i have
also expressed an untruth whether
because i'm confused or a liar or both
or perhaps because i'm afraid of getting
yelled at if i tell the truth
so we should add coward
alongside the options of confused and
liar well one thing i can tell you as a
four-star chef myself um amateur chef
but i consider myself a four-star chef
your kitchen is not complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami coda kamikota taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan
kamikota also uses steel sourced from
mills in japan and each blade is crafted
using techniques that have been honed
and perfected by generations of knife
smiths each knife comes in a beautiful
heavy duty ash wood box and makes sure
that the knife is stored safely as well
each kamikota knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
several years from start to finish to
complete our expert blade smiths forge
and shape raw steel into hardy blades
polishing and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine edge each knife is
individually inspected kamikodo is so
confident that their knives will work
for you that each knife comes with a
lifetime guarantee because of their
single bevel edge kamikoto knives can
achieve an unbelievably sharp edge you
just can't get with other knives they
can cut through your rib eye like butter
that is guaranteed uh kamikoto is
currently having a massive extended new
year sale and on top of that sale you
can get an additional 50 50 off any
purchase you make with discount code
matt walsh so click the link below or go
to
cammacoda.comwalsh and use promo code
matt walsh to save an extra 50
today the pronoun question led directly
to the question the ultimate i mean the
question the ultimate and fundamental
question as far as i'm concerned which
my opponents were not very eager to
answer
that's a question i would like to throw
out to you know other members of the
panel actually because just like the
four-year-old can't answer what is a
girl
well this is one of the problems with
this left-wing gender ideology is that
no one who espouses it
can even tell you what these words means
like what is a woman can you tell me
what a woman is
no i can't
because it's not for me to say i
womanhood looks different for everybody
what do you what do you define a woman
as an adult human female and what does a
female mean
with female reproductive organs
okay someone who's you know here's the
thing when you're when you're female it
goes right down to your bones your dna
so that's why if someone
dies okay we can dig up their bones a
hundred years from now we have no idea
what they believed in their head but we
can tell what sex they were because it's
in it's down in it's it's ingrained in
every fiber of their being interesting
so i'm trying to understand your
definition is that a woman is someone
who is female you said right correct is
a biological female so what happens if
we have maybe someone who is female
identifies as a woman right you know
cisgender woman right as you explain as
you just explained
it maybe doesn't have the ability to
reproduce
maybe doesn't have those organs that
you're talking about that are
reproductive organs i have answered the
question
you stood up here and said trans women
are women yes tell me what you mean what
is a womanhood is something that just as
ethan explained i cannot define because
i am not myself what did you mean when
you said trans women are women if you
don't know what it means right so here's
the thing so i do not define what a
woman is because i do not identify as a
woman womanhood is something that is an
umbrella term it includes people that
describes what
people who identify as a woman i
identify as what as a woman what is that
was to each their own each woman each
man each person is going to have a
different relation with their own gender
identity and define it differently and
so trans women
are women too okay
and you want to hold on transfer
what you would listen to
so you want to reduce women you want to
reduce men down to maybe just their
genetics our genitals our chromosomes
right that's what you want to do is
that's what you what you want to do is
appropriate women you want to
appropriate womanhood okay and turn it
into basically a costume that could be
worn
now the episode continued for another 45
minutes after that but that was really
the end of the conversation i could have
gotten up and walked off the stage right
there which would have been funny um the
other side was there to argue that trans
women are women and that anyone can be a
woman if that's how they feel about
themselves and yet they could not
explain what they meant when they use
that term
trans women are women what's a woman
well who knows
the statement trans women are women
means nothing in that case
they don't know what they mean when they
say it
they don't understand their own position
game over
you notice the obscurantist tactic at
work here because the bearded gentleman
had declared in the previous segment to
the to raucous applause that trans women
are women
and i asked him what he means and he
immediately hopped on the circular logic
merry-go-round rambling a bunch of hazy
gibberish about how only women can
define the word women that doesn't make
any sense because for one thing
he's not an elephant but i'm sure he can
tell me what an elephant is
also even the statement that only women
can define women
requires you to know what a woman is
otherwise how can you know who has the
right to define it and who doesn't
well the answer is that he knows who a
woman is because they're the ones who
say they're women and we know that they
are right in their claims of being women
because they're saying it and they say
they're women because they are women and
they are women because they say they're
women
around and around we go or they go
anyway
they hope to pull you onto the
merry-go-round with them making you as
dizzy and confused as they are which is
why it's important to have simple
answers simple definitions
simple responses and you stick to them
let them twirl around and tie themselves
into knots you're standing on solid
ground
stay there
one more clip worth playing after a very
awkward commercial break where everybody
sat in silence
awkward for them anyway you know i
thought the whole situation was pretty
hilarious we came back with a with a
supposed gender expert and college
professor who provoked applause from the
trained seals in the audience when she
hit me with the old why do you care so
much routine
there's biological sex and then there is
gender identity part of me wants to ask
why you care so much uh because it's
really not that big of a deal oh yeah
um
i i loved that i'd love to answer that
question
i care about the truth so so basic truth
matters i want to live in a society
where people care about the truth and
we're grounded in truth um i care about
children and this these insane ideas
about gender are being are being voiced
on kids
um and that that bothers me quite a bit
i care about the women who are having
their opportunities stolen from them i
care quite a bit yeah
now another point i didn't have the
chance to make there is that um is that
sh
she wants me to care she says why do you
care well i could have said because you
want me to
the other two people on the stage they
want me to care also
their whole job is to go around
insisting that everybody care about this
issue
these people march in literal parades
with banners and floats screaming into
bull horns that we all should care
it's just that they want me to care in
only a very specific way
and to draw very specific conclusions
so when she says why do you care so much
what she really means is why has your
concern about this issue led you to
conclusions that i disapprove of
and so i gave her the answer it's
important to always emphasize that our
first concern
is not fairness it's not sports it's not
privacy it's not even safety
those are all concerns and they're
important but our primary motivation
is to defend truth
for its own sake
if there was a serious campaign to
convince everyone
that squares are circles i'd be arguing
almost as passionately against it i'd
even go on dr phil
to talk about shapes
it's not because i woke up one morning
feeling very passionate about geometry
i didn't choose the fight they're the
ones who decided to wage an assault on
this basic truth and so i can choose to
either surrender the ground to them
or defend it
i don't want to live in a world where
people don't know the difference between
squares and circles i also don't want to
live in a world where people don't know
the difference
between men and women
and it really is as simple as that and
as i said we should keep it simple well
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
matt wall show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content